There is a stunning new claim in an upcoming book
that former Trump adviser, strategist and really
insider Steve Bannon believed that Donald Trump
was already suffering from the early stages of
dementia. This is written up quite concisely in
an article in The Guardian by Martin Pengelley,
where the article says former White House
strategist Steve Bannon thought that Donald
Trump was suffering from early stage dementia and
campaigned to covertly remove him from office via
the 25th Amendment. According to IRA Rosen, a
veteran TV producer. IRA Rosen is the author of
a new book about his work at CBS called Ticking
Clock. Behind the scenes at 60 Minutes, he spoke
to the Yahoo! News podcast Skullduggery and said
to the host, Michael Isikoff and Daniel Klaidman,
that his book was not meant to be about any
particular person, that it was supposed to be
a view about what goes on inside this role of
producer. And when the topic of Stephen Bannon
came up, IRA Rosen said, Steve is a big talker,
a big gossiper, and he became a source for many
media people in Washington and goes on to say that
Steve Bannon, quote, believed Trump was suffering
from early stage dementia and that there was a
real possibility he would be removed from office
by the 25th Amendment, where the cabinet could
vote. The president was no longer mentally capable
of carrying out his duties. He also wrote
that one text message from Bannon said,
You need to do the 25th Amendment piece. By the
way, brother, I never steer you wrong. The idea
being to get a piece aired on CBS about the
idea this is quite, quite early in the game of
using the 25th Amendment to remove Donald Trump.
This is so I mean, listen, there was speculation
about Trump's cognitive faculties for quite some
time. And to hear that someone so close to Trump,
at least for a period of his presidency,
particularly the earlier part of his presidency,
where the concerns were not as great about Trump's
cognitive state. It is it is stunning and it is
incredible. Now, there's a very cynical analysis
here. The the simplest analysis, the one that
requires the fewest assumptions and complications
is this is really what Steve Bannon believed.
And he said it to IRA Rosen.
OK, that's that's the simplest.
Here's a more cynical analysis that a few people
emailed me. Imagine that Steve Bannon wants to
help Trump in some way. Imagine that it is
believed that at some point Donald Trump is
going to face maybe multiple criminal charges in
the state of Georgia, the state of New York. We
know about all these different investigations we
learned last week. Trump is under criminal probe
in Georgia for that supposedly perfect phone call
asking for 11000 votes. What better way to start
mounting a defense for Trump than to start getting
out there early before there is even any charges,
mitigating factors about Donald Trump state
of mind and intent? Because there is no doubt
and this is this is a cynical hypothesis. I'm
not saying it's mine. It's one that I've been
reading that some believe if you are going
to prove some of what would be the likely
crimes, maybe Trump would be accused
of. And this is all very speculative.
A lot of it will be state of mind and intent. What
did Trump believe he was doing? What was Trump's
understanding of the things he was saying and
doing? If you can start planting seeds of doubt,
listen, even Steve Bannon back in twenty
eighteen, whenever this supposedly took place,
even then Steve Bannon was talking about
this guy might have early stage dementia.
That would certainly be a juicy, ripe mitigating
factor for a defense attorney. That's a
cynical perspective. The idea that Trump's best
defense, if he is charged, would be some kind of
insanity defense or unable to even understand
what's going on. Defense. My view is that Steve
Bannon had an inside look at what we all had an
outside look of and there were look at and there
were real questions about Trump's cognitive
state, the videos of Donald Trump saying,
where is Rudy Giuliani when Rudy Giuliani's three
feet across the table from him, Trump coming off
of the plane and wandering off looking for his
car when his car was right there, and a Secret
Service agent taking him by the by the arm and
bringing him back to his car. Trump talking about
the origins of the investigation or, you know.
Dozens of these examples, maybe Steve Bannon
just had an inside look at more of that exact same
stuff, and we have other reports from inside the
White House that sometimes when Trump would say,
I never said that it wasn't that Trump was lying,
it's that Trump's memory was gone. That's another
claim that was made by people close to Trump.
We don't know. We don't know. But there are
both cynical as well as just very literal
interpretations and understandings of what it is
that we are seeing alleged by Steve Bannon here.
Maybe we will learn more about
it than the time to come back t